tout le monde ici est amer nous a dit le
président des supporters
ce jugement quelques jours seulement
après la catastrophe je suis fils de
et c'est encore une fois l'univers
politique montré du doigt
comme si la ville était maudite
jones % stocks ne sait pas aujourd'hui
si elle doit se réjouir ou pleurer
depuis quatre ans elle se bat pour que
les garçons comédie et souhaite à
tout prix un prix très bas prix
mais le pari est risqué c'est la
confusion la plus totale personne ne
sait ce qui va se passer maintenant la
seule chose dont je sois sûr c'est que
rien ne serait pas arrivé si la police
et les organisateurs belges avaient bien
fait leur métier
oui
collomb pris un jour de congé
aujourd'hui ils vont de pommes en
magasin il récupère l'argent donné
par les habitants de liverpool pour
venir en aide aux familles des 95
thèses parle
alors en ce moment
pourquoi ces efforts de tous à ces
fonds j'étais au match du rcl et les
italiens n'ont pas arrêté
si les votants après tout ce qui s'est
passé pourquoi sommes nous les seuls
inculpé ces jeunes sont des boucs
émissaires
lorqu'elle spock commence à peine de se
remplir les supporters du club de
liverpool s'y retrouve après chaque
match et le prochain match dimanche sera
dédiée à la mémoire des 95 victimes
le chef spirituel non